e
e e
good
afternoon welcome to the um house
finance committee I'd like to announce
the uh Replacements we have uh
representative sh replacing
representative Murray representative Gro
for
Buco over here representative Lane for
representative huitt and representative
n is replacing representative F but
we've switched seats so that
representative Mooney can do the
paperwork thank you all for coming um
all the bills before us today are from
division one so I'll turn it over to uh
representative Lehman to introduce the
bills and who's going to make the
reports and remember the reports are
due when we finish today or no later
than tomorrow and if there was there's a
Minority Report which there may be on a
couple of the bills please uh state
who's going to write The Minority Report
thank you representative Lehman thank
you Mr chairman good afternoon Senate
Bill
134 relative to disability pensions for
Public Safety employees who are victims
of violence like the recognize
representative Sweeny thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass
uh thank you Mr chairman uh this bill
establishes a new violent accidental
disability retirement benefit for group
two members the new benefits includes a
violent accidental disability retirement
allowance equal to the members earnable
compensation during their last 12 months
of active service at the date of the
member's disability or an annual
allowance of $775,000 whichever is
greater additionally it provides a
medical subsidy benefit of $1,000 per
month for persons not entitled to
Medicare benefits and $630 63 per per a
month for persons entitled to Medicare
benefits that's obviously the technical
Financial language of the bill uh when
it came to testimony there's two
individuals that this bill would affect
and and so just passing it uh fixes an
an error in the system that was
overlooked any further discussion on
Senate Bill
134 being none are you ready for the
question clerk will call the rooll on
the motion of ought to pass on Senate
Bill 134
FN thank you Mr
chairman uh representative Mooney
yes representative uh Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative emri yes representative
Griffin
yes representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney yes representative cambrell yes
represent papich M yes representative
walner representative Lehman yes
representative
Grody yes representative
Lane yes representative Heath
represent
sh sorry I didn't quite understand you
yes what's cor shoot is a shoot sh it oh
I had it
right
rot gr okay representative Eble yes
resident
tersi yes resent haen Phillips yes
resident Stringham yes representative
grassy yes representative priest yes
representative Wier
yes oh snuck in there didn't
you okay repres okay you can be number
25 representative representative na yes
sorry about that I'm doing so much
skipping here Mr chairman the vote is 25
to Z in favor of the motion
and representative Sweeney will write
the
report and that'll be in the uh since it
does spend money it'll be have to be on
the regular
calendar now Senate Bill 337 represent
LE thank you Mr chairman uh this bill is
relative to douas and lactation Services
providers uh certification and I didn't
know what duelas was so I did learn
something there i' like to recognize
represent and a
evil thank you very much Mr chair I move
um ought to pass for SB 337 I'll second
that okay thank you um so for those that
don't know what a doula is a doula
provides uh support for new mothers in
particular who are um breastfeeding and
to to help that whole process uh to date
that has not been reimbursable by
Medicaid and it's hoped with this bill
uh that it will be um in particular this
will pay or give money to the oplc to
support lure for the duelas and also uh
from a revenue standpoint there will be
a fee associated with lure and um it was
felt within the division that this was a
very worthwhile service that should be
supported so I urge the committee to
vote on to pass
thank you further discussion on Senate
Bill
337 seeing none clerk will call a role
on the motion of ought to pass on Senate
Bill
337 thank you Mr chairman representative
Mooney
yes representative ner yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vs yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes repres
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative
walner representative Lehman
yes representative Grody yes Ro
groa representative Lane
yes representative Heath yes
representative Shu
yes representative eel yes
representative torski
yes repr haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassy yes representative priest yes
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 25 to Z in favor of the
motion 25 to0 for oop pass and the
report will be written by represent
AEL recognize represent Lehman for
Senate Bill 347 thank you Mr chairman
this is relative to infrastructure
Appropriations reimbursement for the
city of lonia i' like to recognize
representative Maguire
thank you Mr chairman I move itl on
consent I'll second that
motion so this is a bill that would have
spent uh $3
million of the money that from the sale
of the Laconia property for
infrastructure um for the new project
for the for the buyer but that wh sale
fell through we don't know what the
property will eventually be used for so
therefore the spending is unnecessary
F the discussion or questions on on
Senate Bill
347 seeing none the clerk will call the
role on inexpedient to legislate for
Senate Bill
347 thank you Mr
chairman representative Mooney
yes representative ner yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative uh Edward
Edwards yes
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes represented Campbell
yes representa Popovich meller yes
representa
Walder representa Lehman yes
representative groy yes
res lean yes res of Heath yes res of Shu
yes res
evil yes res torski
yes res haen Phillips yes resident
Stringham resident grassy yes resent
priest yes resent Wier yes Mr chairman
the vote is 25 to Z in favor of the
motion
the motion being 25 to Zer inexpedient
to legislate this can go on the consent
calendar Senate Bill
347 next recognize representative
leechman for Senate Bill
369 thank you Mr chairman this is
directing the office of professional
licensure and certification to provide
notice of public meetings and the
opportunity to comment creating a new
position and making an appropriation
therefore I'd like to recognize is
representative Sweeny thank you Mr
chairman I move a to pass second
it
evil speak to my motion uh if this bill
sounds very familiar to you it should
it's a policy that we supported last
year uh the house voted it on the
consent calendar uh the corner office
had a slight uh disagreement with it
which resulted in a veto uh the bill
came back the senate had passed it as
this way we we are adopting the changes
that are amable uh to the this can
become law and it's uh so it's pretty
straightforward and
simple thank you any further questions
or discussions on Senate Bill
369 seeing none the cler will call the
rooll on the motion of ought to pass
Senate Bill
369 thank you Mr
chairman representative Mooney yes
representative Maguire yes
representative ner
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Campell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative Waller uh walner I'm
sorry
representative Lehman yes
representative Lane let me see I'm sorry
um Gro day
yes representa Lane yes
yes representative Heath
yes representative Shu
yes represent of evil yes
yes represent torki yes represent hien
Phillips yes represent Stringham yes
representative grassie
yes represent priest yes represent wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to zero in
favor the
motion okay the uh ought to pass on
Senate Bill
369 this does spend money I believe so
it will go on the regular calendar and
representative Sweeney will write this
report as
well next Rec recognize representative
Lehman for Senate Bill
393 thank you Mr chairman this is
relative to making appropriation to the
Department of Environmental Services for
funds to fund re uh Regional drinking
water infrastructure like to thank
representative Sweeney for offering an
amendment and recognize representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman uh at this
time I would move Amendment 1793 H to
Senate Bill 393 and it's being
distributed uh just to really quickly
explain uh this bill came to us from the
Senate with a $25 million appropriation
in a mixture of General funds and
federal funds uh in working with the
Department of Environmental Services
they weren't uh the timeline wasn't
there for a project this year of that
scale uh so this has been scaled down
significantly to a $2 million general
fund appropriation and $4.5 million in a
combination of federal funds and the
drinking water trust fund uh that the
state of New Hampshire operates uh in
order to do design and Engineering of
the next phase of the Southern New
Hampshire Regional water line the
partner towns in those municipalities
are partnering up for Federal grant
applications to help fund the next phase
of the project uh but by passing this
bill today we can do the design and
engineering and scope out the project so
that that come the next capital budget
we can look at our options for financing
the rest of the Southern Regional water
line which will go to support
infrastructure in the in the 93 Southern
93 tier uh from Manchester down
throughout Southern Rockingham and
Hillsboro counties so a lot of good work
went into this from the department and
the stakeholders and I just want to
thank them all for for working with us
on it so thank you any questions on the
amendment I'm not sure it was seconded
so I'll second it so representative Abel
you second thank you if there's no
objection we'll adopt the amendment by a
show of hands all in favor of adopting
Amendment 1793 raise your
hand hands down any any opposed seeing
none it's unanimously
adopted the motion now is ought to pass
as amended by Amendment
1793 on Senate Bill
393 if there's no further discussion the
clerk will call the role on the motion
have ought to pass as amended Senate
Bill
393 thank you Mr
chairman representative Mooney yes
representative nter yes represent
McGuire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney
yes representative
camell yes represent papichi Muller yes
representative
walner representative Lehman
yes representative grot yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative Shu yes
representable
yes represent torki yes yes
representative haaken Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent grassy
yes represent priest yes represent wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 deserve in
favor of the
motion the vote being 25 to Z on Senate
Bill 393 on the motion of ought to pass
as
amended and it will go on the regular
calendar because it spends
money and
that's quite an accomplishment division
three all that agreement division one
excuse me all that agreement we're a
great group Mr chairman couldn't have a
better group of people pleased to hear
that Senate Bill 303 uh
recognize representative
Lehman 403
403 thank you Mr chairman this is
relative to Health Care Workforce like
to recognize representative
walner thank you pres
bman what the bill does is it extends um
the work of the commission on
interdisciplinary Primary Care Workforce
it allows for the Board of Nursing to
issue a certificate of medication
administration to current licensed nurse
assistants l l
lnas uh who meet certain
criterias um and it requires the
Department of Health and Human Services
to submit a
title oh I don't know how many a title
19 I believe it is Medicaid State Plan
amendment to allow for the reimbursement
of services provided by certified um
community health care
workers and it um allows the division of
Public Health within the Department of
Health and Human Services to contract
with community-based organizations to
connect individual and families with
proper support to manage health
care and the financial uh part of this
bill is there is no there is no
um appropriation but on page four of the
bill I will read to you how this uh
particular bill will be funded the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of Public Health May contract
with community- based organizations in
in including community health centers
Family Resource Centers to deploy
sustain and sustain community health
care workers that connect families and
patients with needed health and
Supportive Services the department may
use federal funds where available and
general funds within the Department's
existing budget upon approval of the
fiscal committee to sustain the work of
the community healthcare workers through
the fiscal year of June 30
2025 so there is no um
appropriation at this point they can use
um funding that they have within their
budget by coming to the fiscal committee
to pay for these community healthcare
worker
Services further
discussion any questions seeing none the
motion is ought to pass on Senate Bill
403 the clerk will call a role on that
motion thank you Mr
chairman representative Moody yes
representative ner yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin
no representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes
represent Sweeney yes represent camell
yes representative papich Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative leechman yes
representative grot yes representative
Lane yes representative Heath yes
representative Shu yes represent eel yes
represent torski yes
representative hen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
represent grassy yes representative
priest
yes representative wer
no two Mr chair the vote is
23 to
two in favor of the motion okay the
motion is adopted as ought to pass
23-2 I don't think there'll be a
Minority
Report and uh representative walner will
write the report for Senate Bill
403 uh for Senate Bill 407 recognizing
representative Lehman thank you Mr
chairman this is establishing a ground
ambulance cost reporting program and a
study by an independent Actuarial and an
accounting expert of the cost of
providing ground ambulance services in
the state like to recognize
representative
grassy thank you Mr chairman I would uh
recommend a to
pass further discussion um Mr chairman
uh this bill has no Financial impact on
the state whatsoever the data to do this
uh to do the study already exist and uh
so it should be something that should be
done relatively quickly thank you very
good question question represent Edwards
uh it it was my understanding that the
state had not employed an actuary if
where where where would the actuary come
from to provide the independent report
uh my understanding this work was all
recently done for uh Medicare Medicare
and Medicaid and so that the data is out
there and all the information is
available already it was just done the
last couple years so they're just going
to be updating the information they have
they would not really need to do
anything within the they could do within
the department thank
you representa Stringham did you have
anything further I I ju Just just that
that activity was part of the ambulance
uh review group uh put on by beton Court
last summer so there was a tremendous
amount of uh financial information
coming in I haven't seen any of it
compiled very good thank you further
discussion seeing none The Click will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass on Senate Bill 407
thank you Mr chairman representative
money yes representative uh nder yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative Campell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
represent
walner representative Lehman yes
grot yes represent leene yes
representative Heath yes represent Shu
yes representative eel yes president
Tori yes resent haen Phillips yes
president Stringham yes president grassy
yes presid priest yes pres Wier yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to zero in favor of
the
motion the motion of ought to pass is
passed for Senate Bill 407 that can go
on the consent calendar since there is
no money
consent recognize represent lean for
Senate Bill
453 thank you Mr chairman this is making
an appropriation to the Statewide voter
registration system and I understand
representative Maguire would like to
offer a recommendation of interim study
yes I would thank you um so all right
so we had new we have new since we met
we met and and this uh we didn't have
any problem with this um uh bill because
we were told that everybody liked it the
both our election law committee and the
and the one from the Senate and so on
but since then there this is just the
appropriation and there's a companion
bill which I unfortunately don't know
the number of but um we're told that the
Senate is going to itl the companion
bill which has the policy involved in
creating this this uh voter registration
portal and therefore this spending is
unnecessary
so it seems to me that the an interim
study motion is uh is appropriate
because if the Senate decides they
actually you know change their mind yet
again and go forward with that bill they
can ask for a committee of conference on
this bill and then we can agree to to
passing it but but assuming that they're
going to go forward with their current
plans and not pass that bill then this
bill doesn't make sense so interim study
questions further
discussion representative papich Mueller
you
seconded it's already been seconded has
published representan question
representative Lane um thank you I would
just ask uh representative McGuire um
when that vote was
taken I understand maybe representative
Sweeney can comment but I understand it
was a committee vote but not yet a floor
vote in the Senate so there's still
still time to argue with them if that's
what you'd like to
do further
discussion represent walner yes thank
you so explain to me what would happen
if the Senate um moved ahead and um did
pass the bill then there wouldn't be an
appropriation so this sort of like is it
the horse before the cart or the cart
before the
horse yeah so thank you for the question
so again I think if they decide to go
ahead then they will ask us for comme of
conference on this bill oh is that not
true so we we'd have to we can't right
well if you if you know that they've
passed this before we have an action in
the house then you could have a floor
amendment to pass to make this bill out
to pass I see you say yeah yeah yeah Mr
Mr chairman Mr chairman would it be
appropriate to uh basically table this
bill till tomorrow
so we can have some further discussion
about this outside of the meeting and
find out what's going on and and I think
it would be a good idea to put it off we
put it at the end of end of agenda
tomorrow I I think that's okay without a
problem we'll uh take this one up
tomorrow any
objection yeah go talk to your Senate
the
counterparts all right all right bye
delay judgment on that one till we know
more and we'll be meeting again tomorrow
to discuss bills from this
committee all
right recognize representative Lehman
for Senate Bill
476 thank you Mr chairman this is making
a capital appropriation to the
Department of Corrections towards the
replacement of the New Hampshire state
prison for men like to recognize
representative
evil thank you very much um I move ought
to pass on Senate Bill 47
76 second okay motion and second V to
pass on Senate Bill 476 would you like
to go into the finances of it I would um
so this bill proposes to um appropriate
$40 million which is admittedly a large
amount um this would be uh Capital
appropriation so it would be raised
through bonds the expend
for interest is estimated to be about uh
$4.6
million annually um commissioner Hanks
came and spoke to us about the uh
condition of the prison and you heard
quite a bit about the condition of the
prison from chair makoni who heads up
Public Works and highways in our last um
session when we talked at length about
the condition of the prison
we did ask the treasurer to come in and
chat with us because obviously this is a
large um amount of money it is off cycle
it's out of the capital budget in the
last capital budget we appropriated 10
million even though the request was for
50 the upshot is for this uh amount of
money it would be for the architectural
engineering programming design and
construction documents for a new prison
for the men um you know you can't kick
the can down the road forever and at
some point we have to uh start to move
forward because we recognize that the
condition of the men's uh prison if
you've ever been there you know this and
if you haven't take our word for it um
it it it needs um it needs something uh
the commissioner made a very effective
uh present ation about the millions and
millions and millions of dollars it was
going to take to uh maintain the prison
um if we didn't replace it and also
there are litigation concerns always
when you let uh the prison deteriorate
which we experienced with the women's
prison which I think we can all agree we
put off too long um we asked quite a few
questions and we were convinced uh not
only the desirability of moving forward
with this uh we um were satisfied that
the amount that they were talking about
for the appropriation was uh the right
amount and of course it could uh go down
we did talk about other models of
Prisons that were being built that we
could look at um and all in all
especially after our conversation with
the with the treasurer we were convinced
um unanimously
that we should go forward with this bill
so on that basis I would ask the
committee to join division one and vote
ought to pass thank you further
discussions comments questions
representative Maguire yes thank you Mr
chairman I I would agree that this is
some this is a big expenditure and it's
just the start uh we're told that the
prison eventually will cost something
like 550 million but we're talking about
a capital expenditure that will be uh
you know used by the state for many many
decades and so it's appropriate to
borrow the money and the current state
of the prison in conquered is horrible
and and it needs to be um it needs to be
changed and and needs to be updated and
the good news is that the biggest
expense of the Corrections Department is
personnel we're currently spending in
excess of
$70,000 per inmate for operational
expenses and the design of a prison can
be done in a much more efficient way
than it was back in the 18 whatevers
when when conquered was designed and so
therefore it's possible by having a new
prison we will we will save money on the
operational aspects of
that represent Edwards for question uh
thank you I I don't know if that was
humor or not you said the prison was
built in the 1800s could you do you we
have a real date for the opening of the
prison well the original building was
actually uh built I believe before the
state house um because I understand that
the architect who did the state house
got the job because he had designed the
prison and and got it in under budget on
time and under
budg and so
yeah yeah so I guess the the but that
building it's on the same location but
that building which was because the
State House is
1819 um and the prison the original
building at the prison was was um 18
like 15 or something like that that
building's no longer there but the the
current building is 1878 and then there
are newer buildings also
thank you that's a very old building
yeah yeah it's 150 years you know
so further
discussion seeing none the motion is
ought to pass on Senate Bill 476
FN seeing no further discussion the
clerk will call the role on that
motion thank you Mr chairman represent
Mooney yes president McGuire
yes represent m a notter i didn't forget
you I just
yes and representative
Petri representative Emer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes Representative
hle
no
um representative Sweeney
yes resent Campell yes papovich Muller
yes
represent
walner yes represent Lehman
yes representative grod yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative Shu yes
representative evil yes representative
torski yes representative haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes resident
grassy
yes resident priest yes
president wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 24 to one in
favor of the
motion motion of about to pass is
adopted 24 to1 will there be a Minority
Report representative
hold Representative hle no no minority
okay and representative AEL will write
the
report it's regular calendar because it
spends some money
recognize representative Lehman for
Senate Bill
480 thank you Mr chairman this is
relative to the regulation of real
estate practice like to recognize
representative
Griffin thank you uh Mr chair I uh move
Senate Bill 480 ought to pass second
uh further discussion the bill defines
post
licensing and provides both Ina
voluntary inactive service status and
non-voluntary inactive service status it
also provides requirements for an active
status as well as a process for the
reinstatement to active status from
inactive status there is no appropriate
in this
bill uh as most of you know I'm a CPA
but I've also held a real estate license
since I was aged
19 and I've only given it up in the last
few
years um as best I could tell from read
carefully reading this bill it doesn't
change a lot of the current practice it
does
clarify that a realtor who earns a
commission as active
status can collect that commission after
becoming inactive
status and uh other than that it's it's
pretty much the just relates how things
have been going and redefines so it
defines
postlicensing period which I believe is
uh from the time the license is issued
till the time it's first
renewed did I hear you say say that
there's no cost there there is no
appropriation with this Bill thank
you all right further discussion on
Senate Bill
480 seeing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass on
Senate Bill
480 and here we go thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney yes representative
n
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative uh Edwards
yes representative uh Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney yes representative camell yes
representative papovich meller yes
representative walner yes representative
Lehman yes representative gray yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes repr Shu yes represent eil yes
represent sori
yes pres hen Phillips yes resent
Stringham yes pres grassy yes pres
priest yes pres wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 25 to Zer in favor of the
motion Senate Bill 480 FN is adopted as
ought to pass it can go on the consent
calend since there is no money in it
recognize representative Lehman for
Senate Bill
487 thank you Mr chairman this is
relative to the division of Personnel in
the department of administrative
services and again I'd like to recognize
representative
Griffin Mr chair I move are to pass on
Senate Bill
487 okay motion a second on not to pass
on Senate Bill 487 further discussion
repres
Griffin um this bill moves the uh
Personnel appeals board out of the
Department of administrative
services and it establishes it as an
independent entity from all other state
agencies there is no appropriation with
this bill and apparently will be uh
funded
internally thank you further discussion
seeing none clerk will call the role on
the motion about to pass on Senate Bill
487 thank you Mr
chairman representative Mooney yes
representative nder
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative be yes representative hle
yes
repres Sweeney yes represent caml
yes represent Popovich Muller yes repr
walner
yes representative Lehman
yes uh representative Grody
yes representative
uh Lan
yes pres of Heath yes
okay who
replaced sorry about
that Che
yes represent vble
yes represent torki yes represent haken
Phillips yes ver a Stringham yes ver a
grassy yes ver a priest
yes representative wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z in
favor of the motion motion of ought to
pass is adopted on Senate Bill 487 if
there is no money in this we can put
this on
consent recognize representative Lehman
for Senate Bill
553 thank you Mr chairman this is
requiring that funds held by the public
deposit investment pool be invested in
New Hampshire like to recognize
representative Sweeney who has an uh an
amendment for us and thank him for his
efforts thank you Mr chairman so there
is an amendment being passed around for
this I actually am waiting on a revised
version of this amendment I think we'll
be able to get it after the next two
bills if we could hold on to this debate
until the the end of work today um so I
could discuss the other am the only
difference between the amendment that's
being passed around and the amend that
we'll be getting from OS is the new
amendment has a sunset provision of 2030
for the policies that are in this bill
to require a revision a review in 2030
legislative session so that's the only
substantive difference between what you
see in front of you and what will be
discussing when we have the final
Amendment all right
we'll we'll move on then we'll uh put
that later in the calendar for Senate
Bill 553 and recognize now
representative lean for Senate Bill
591 thank you Mr chairman this is
modifying definitions claims procedures
and funding related to the Youth
Development Center settlements fund and
claims Administration I understand
representative Maguire perhaps has a new
Amendment yes I don't know that I have
it do I have
it we don't have the amendment yet all
right we don't have the amendment yet on
that one so I could it's it's a really
short one so I could describe it if you
wanted to talk about this cuz this might
well we'll we'll all right we'll wait
for go action on that until people have
the amendment in front of them or
something close it may have to take till
tomorrow if it's not ready
today uh I'll recognize representative
Lehman for Senate Bill
604 thank you Mr chairman this is
providing a death benefit for a New
Hampshire hospital security officer
killed in the line of duty like to
recognize representative
Griffin thank you thank you Mr
chair uh I move on to pass with
Amendment on uh Senate Bill
604 Motion in a second on I've not seen
the
amendment Senate Bill 604 I suspect it's
okay I just want to see it
okay we have it
now I I do I 20 seconds if I
may did I speak to the amendment yes you
may yeah basically what the
uh the amendment does two
things uh one there was a question
raised about the constitutionality of
the bill making a uh making a payment to
an individual rather than a class of
individuals and uh the amendment
addresses that
issue uh by incorporating it into the
bill and uh the second thing the uh the
amendment does is it uh it includes uh
well part of part of making it
constitutional is includes security
officers with police officers as those
who were killed in the line of duty U
are eligible for the $100,000 payment
the police officers are eligible for uh
the second thing the bill does is it
clarifies that it's only full-time
police offices and
full-time uh
security uh it's only for fulltime uh
police officers permanent permanent
security officers that will be eligible
for
this I
think represent Maguire thank you Mr
chairman
so
um yes so so most of that was was
completely correct so this was the bill
to pay $100,000 to the family of Officer
hos who was killed at New Hampshire
hospital
uh very tragically and so
um and the reason and and we have an
existing um we have an existing benefit
for those that are killed in the line of
duty and it includes not just um police
officers but also firemen and um Public
Works officers and so on there's a whole
list and so this the reason that um
officer 's case didn't apply is because
he was a part-time security officer at
the hospital and security officers were
not on the list so the last line 24 of
the amendment adds security officers to
the
list but
um but the uh in reading that whole
section of law we also pay this um this
benefit in certain circumstances that
include
suicide and the argument there is that
suicide is uh can frequently be the
result of
PTSD it's job related and so but since
I'm adding some part-time people to this
list it seems to me that um that if
you're if your job is going to create a
PTSD type situation that would be for
full-time full-time employees and not
part-time so this
eliminates the U cause of this uh
payment in cases of suicide of
part-timers and and keeps it in the case
of full-timers
so representative Edwards for a question
uh thank you Mr chair I I had uh
submitted an amendment um uh that draft
was drafted by OS to representative
Maguire and to representative Lee
uh I did that Amendment after
consultation with um one of the Senators
who is the key sponsor of the of the
bill and uh based on my understanding of
the facts uh Mr hos was a contractor he
he was not employed by the state and and
so the the intent of my amendment was to
incorporate Mr hass's uh death uh uh
gratuiti that's not the right word but
uh the death benefit the to to to
basically say that if we have contracted
out a
Frontline Security role that those
positions also would be included in the
future and and I I did that to make sure
that he was in the right category
assuming he was a contractor and and I I
just don't think it's good precedent for
us to be doing benefits by name after
the fact I think we should look for
categorical opportunities and and I'm
not I so I guess my first question sir
is what status was Mr hon I I understood
he was a contractor not an employee and
if and if that's the case line 24
doesn't do it for
me well I've heard from Senate a senator
as well and he says there's others
believe with him the family has said
they just want a clean bill that
recognizes him they don't want any other
amendments they don't want any other
people included in it and so if we put
in an amendment it's it looks acceptable
to me but if it if we vote this
amendment in and it goes to a committee
of conference then the Senate will
likely want this amendment removed just
a heads up um at least we've heard from
some of the Senators on this this
amendment his name is still in the Bill
yes right this this is rather than make
new categories we could just just by
saying passing the bill with the person
named you don't have to worry about what
category he was in what his employment
status was if there's a bill that names
him that's
sufficient so representative Sho you had
a comment thank you Mr chair um I've
been pretty heavily involved in this
section of the RSA uh having sponsored
the portion that included the Public
Works employees uh as as soon as Chief
hos was uh killed I made similar
inquiries to representative Edwards and
I agree he was a different category I
would add a further
complication uh the the term including
suicide but the end of that sentence
says while in the performance of his or
her duties I would submit it's very rare
that someone commits suicide while they
are performing their duties it's usually
while they're off duty so I think that's
a a further complication that this
amendment uh puts
forward further comments representa hle
thank you Mr chair um to the prior
comment I believe that the issue
regarding involving suicide comma right
in the performance of his or her duties
is current law so we're not making a
change there um
I have always had concerns about when we
start um addressing suicide with a death
benefit that we potentially have an
unintended consequence of encouraging
someone who's facing severe depression
already that they now have yet a
financial um incentive to end their life
it's not that's not the purpose of this
bill it but it has
been there is an issue of an unintended
consequence when you allow suicide side
to be included but that's not the
purpose of this bill this is regarding a
person who was employed either directly
or indirectly by the state of New
Hampshire as a security guard um
guarding the state hospital potentially
a place that could be dangerous he was
at the metal detector um it is my
understanding from news reports he was
still alive by the time he made it to
the
hospital
and the underlying cause of what led to
this un tragic circumstances hasn't been
addressed or sorry is currently being
addressed by new rfps by the department
to make sure security guards are in fact
armed at our various institutions um
disarming a security guard is a real
danger to their life um so I I agree
with what we're trying to do for changes
here I just want to make sure that um
this passes muster relative to um
retroactive
law someone else
representative Edwards uh thank you uh
I'm I'm going to assume that
representative Shu has confirmed what I
said that the that Mr hos was serving as
a contractor at the time of U of his
being shot to death and I very much want
to help uh their family and support
their family talking to the uh Senator
um I think that was you talked to as
well he I was supposed to be given the
phone number so I could talk to the
family and that number
never came to me as a promised um or I
would have checked on it personally that
that that this alternative approach
would be good uh I I I'm I'm I would
like to ask either representative Lehman
or Maguire if they have a copy of the
amendment I emailed them I'd like the
ability to enter that Amendment into
discussion unfortunately I don't see
think I ever saw that amendment I don't
know if representative mgu did or yeah I
I did um I don't know if LBA has it it
should have my name on it Edwards I
don't know um yeah I can you know if you
gave if you want to recess for for eight
minutes or something I can print them
yeah I I entire I entirely want to
protect their family but I I want to do
it in a way in which um we're not doing
one-offs retroactively it just it just
looks
uh inappropriate from a principal and
consistency
perspective represent Heath for a
question thank you um Mr chair I too um
have spoken with um some of the Senators
and their intent in this bill was to
honor this man for what he did um for
his family and I think that we're
getting away from that intent and
purpose I mean this is our way that we
can honor him for giving his life for us
um and for so many at the state hospital
so I would love to see this bill go
forward unamended as is so that we can
honor um this man in the manner in which
he should be honored thank you very
much further
discussion representative lean then I'll
come back to you and representative
walner yeah just a followup to
representative Heath it would certainly
be cleaner if you if you look at the as
it came to us from the Senate it doesn't
matter whether he's a contractor or
anyone else he was shot and killed and I
think we should honor this bills that
came forward is it says here a
department of safety security officer
whether he was in a contract or again
part-time employee I think we really
ought to move this forward and uh pass
$100,000 appropriation without mucking
it up represent
walner I would agree um and it if um
there needs to
be amendments to this particular
language about death by Suicide it seems
to me it's not in this bill I mean this
is not the time or the place to be doing
that it should have had a public hearing
um it's a whole another subject matter
and um for that I think we should go to
the original
Bill okay we'll wait till representative
McGuire comes back in representative
Edwards again so so I just I just want
to make sure that people understands the
understand the Deep sympathy I have for
this family
I I've served with people who've died in
the line of duty I get
it I just think that it's important for
us to to honor the family and to do it
in the right principled way and that is
not a call out simply by name if the
goal is to honor him we can do that in a
resolution I I I I don't think that's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
appropriate $100,000 to for for a
particular purpose for a particular
person that benefits and that's all it's
all okay but I think there's a better
way to do it and I I really would like
uh you all to just maintain an open mind
until you can see what I the am the
amendment I'd like to bring forward R
zone a hold and then pres groa thank you
Mr chair
um if you had asked me the day after
this un unfortunate tragic murder
whether he was covered I would have
thought yes based on the job he was
serving um I'm aware of the the death
benefit policy that's been in statute
for a number of years and I would have
said he would have been qualified under
the
prior
language um but for the technicalities I
go I guess and the fact that we had
someone serving um to protect other
employees to protect our patients as a
security guard who was then murdered on
the job um who was not
covered I think we need to do something
but I also know that we need to at some
point address the underlying policy and
I think that was the attempt of the
committee to make sure that those
positions in the future that are serving
that that role of security um are in
fact
protected representative groda
thank you Mr chair coming from a policy
committee that often addresses these
matters I would recommend to this
committee that you pass the bill
unamended and leave it as is and then
address this issue on a policy issue so
that we know we have it in the right
place because this amendment right now
is at odds with what is in St statute
and we don't want to create a situation
where you have things conflicting or not
in compliance or meshing so that would
be my agreement I understand
representative Edwards position and I
agree with it and sympathize I just
don't think that this amendment is the
right thing for the right for right now
that's my recommendation to you thank
you thank you all right is represent
Maguire back yet no
he did find my Amendment and we're just
making copies now my my copy doesn't
address the issue of suicide at all I I
would I don't think that's appropriate
for this
bill okay we have uh one Amendment
before us from
representative is that representative
Maguire's
Amendment yes
all
right representa McGuire there's not
great acceptance among the group for
your Amendment but we'll put it up for a
vote if you want to move
it would you like to discuss the
alternative first sure if you've got it
and it's being handed
out so uh this or maybe representative
Edwards would like to speak I I can
speak to it if uh
permitted Mr chair you already recognize
to spe all right so um so I wanted to
verify a few things with OS the key
thing I wanted to verify was uh that it
was constitutional to do a retroactive
benefit and in indeed it is uh and
there's precedent for it so those people
worried about the constitutionality of
looking back to to provide a benefit
they don't they don't need to concern
themselves too much about that what what
my Amendment does is it inserts at line
11 and 12 um a simple line that says
department of safety security officers
assigned to provide public facing
Security Services whether contracted or
employed directly and and and and what
that gets at is this would put it into
statute where Mr hos would uh his family
would benefit from this amendment and
and be eligible for the death benefit so
uh and it does it in a way in which I
think we preserve um the the the
principles of not assigning specific
state benefits to specific
individuals thank you um one would argue
if they were in the Edna committee that
that was their po policy area and you in
the finance committee shouldn't be doing
policy independent of that committee
that's just something we may hear
so do either of you wish to move an
amendment I I would like to move um my
Amendment
20241 1599 Hotel I'll second okay um do
we you have an extra uh sheet to call
the role second Mr chairman
question yes is it an intent to take Mr
hass's name off the bill because that's
what you're doing by this
amendment that wasn't an intent but that
would be a consequence um so there there
could be a way to uh to tweak this so
that it doesn't remove his name uh from
the underlying
bill I like I said I I think his family
should be honored this is a legislative
act
um the sequence of event would be such
that um if this was amended it would go
back to the Senate there'd be a
committee of conference and it would
have to go to the governor and so on if
we passed the bill as it came to us from
the Senate then it would go and we
didn't make any changes it would go
right to the governor and it would
expedite perhaps the payment to the
family just just for further comment Mr
chairman I think that if we're going to
do something like this I think there's
been a lot of discussion here today that
maybe this is something for further
legislation next year uh not to do this
if you know we supported in those of us
in division one supported the amendment
as it was to try to add these other
positions in but I think it's
complicating the issue and I think that
what we need to do is pass the the bill
as it came to us send it to the
governor's desk it it achieves what we
want to achieve all this other stuff is
additional legislation I think needs to
be dealt with by the policy committee
next session representative Hall thank
you Mr chair um relative to the naming
if we left the title in the bill and on
line six said amend the bill by
replacing section two instead of all
after the enacting Clause the title of
the bill would still be there relative
to officer um Bradley hos but it would
address
concurrently the Gap in our statutes
relative to someone who is serving as
security um and that Amendment could be
easily drafted for tomorrow morning
which would be this text with one
additional line being the current
title so I guess we have a motion before
us for Amendment
1599 so to dispose of that Amendment
we'll call for a roll
call all right let's all right show of
hands all in favor of 1599 raise your
hand one
two three four five all oppos raise your
hand the majority says no
all right Amendment defeated
by
hands representative McGuire do you wish
to move an
amendment but you already told me my
amendments won't pass right so said I
already told you what while I was out of
the room no what no we did not vote on
it without you being here oh I see I
wouldn't do that well no but you said
that it wasn't uh I well all right fine
I I will move Amendment 1695 H so this
has the advantage it still set has the
paragraph with with officer hass's name
and it's it's very similar to the one we
just proposed it's just that it doesn't
have the word Contracting under security
officers it has this security officer
line right so further discussion on
Amendment
1695 wa a second I'll second it for
discussion but I will not be supporting
the amendment representative leean
seconded further discussion seeing none
I assume you're ready for the vote we'll
do it again by raising hands all those
in favor of amendment 1695 H raise your
hand two
three all those
opposed overwhelmingly
defeated
okay we still have before for us I
believe a motion of ought to pass is
that was that what you made
representative Griffin and representa
Sweeney seconded a motion of ought to
pass I I will change my motion to ought
to pass on Senate Bill
604 without any Amendment make it clear
that it's ought to pass without any
Amendment Mr chair represent Sweeney
second further discussion representative
Edwards is out of the room and I think
he would probably like to be included in
the vote I'll wait for him to return I
didn't even notice him
leave represent papich Miller thank you
Mr chair while we are waiting for
representative Edwards I know that he
was suggesting that he would like to um
redraft his amendment in order to
address at least some of the concerns of
the committee and under the
circumstances I was wondering if maybe
it would be appropriate to give him you
know until tomorrow to do so and uh then
we can consider that Amendment and then
dispose of the bill it would not impact
our ability to put the bill on the same
house calendar I hope we can move
through the schedule tomorrow as quickly
as we have
today so we also agreed to put off
553 which we had an amendment before us
that people wanted a chance to read and
I wonder if if we are ready to take
action on
553 we did we didn't have a
it was it was put before you look
through your stack it might be buried
under one of the other amendments so Mr
chairman we do have 188h but we don't it
have the newest version that includes
the sunset language this is what this is
not the new the latest version of the
amendment we're still waiting so we're
going to have to wait till tomorrow on
that
one uh either if we can get it before
the end of day today or tomorrow we can
do it tomorrow we're about to wrap up
for the day because everything else we
have has been
put off for also Senate Bill 591 has an
amendment coming no all right are we
ready to take some action on Senate Bill
591 and do we have an amendment we do
not have the uh representative McGuire's
Amendment for 591 on 591 yeah okay so
we're delaying action on 553 591 and 604
is that correct
last
three Mr chair could I please ask for
clarification again why are we delaying
604 pleasa I'm sorry I didn't
understand um wait Ed we were waiting
for the return of represent Edwards for
the motion of just simply ought to pass
and decided to wait for him to return
before we head that
vote representative T thank you Mr
chairman I just don't know if if a
recess of till maybe 2:30 could be would
be enough time or not I'm looking to the
LBA people is that your request I'm
wondering if they believe that if we
recess to 230 if there's a chance the
Amendments would be drafted by then I
don't know I'm directing the question
through you to them all right
and LBA any question any answer to that
I think that would give OS a little bit
more time to draft these because they
just got them before lunch so all right
we'll take a break till till 2:30 and
see if we can wrap up any of the these
other events thank
you finance committee will be in recess
till
2:30
e
e e
all right you may have some amendments
in your place you can look at while
we're waiting to call us back to
order
e
e e
waiting on oh no she is
okay who's gone uh Connie Lane oh she's
right there 20 more seconds
okay so we're gonna voting 64 straight
up right right just
is it being 2:30 I'll call the finance
committee back from recess and we'll
continue we have before us an active uh
a to pass without Amendment ought to
pass on Senate Bill
604 uh we took some a moment for
everybody to look at that and realize it
was just a h Bill and nothing else so
everyone understand it is there any
further
discussion and we have a member that
says he won't be back representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman so I'm I'm
opposed to the B the reason whole reason
I wanted to amend the bill in the first
place and not is not to not pay uh
officer H's family but I have a problem
that I think the bill as written is
unconstitutional by part one article 10
so in my reading of part one article 10
of our
constitution we cannot simply write a
check and and pay someone specifically
by name that's the problem and and we
can we can set policy and have benefits
and all those kind of things but to but
to single out a specific person you know
if I I couldn't you know write a check
to you know Joe Smith um uh and make a
bill like that right so um so that's
what this bill effectively does now of
course there's good reasons and all that
sort of stuff but I think we want I
wanted an amendment to make it General
right so that it's it's not we're not
writing a check to a specific person
we're writing a check to someone in this
situation right what part of the
Constitution are you talking about part
one article 10 well how does it read
well I can I can quote it to you if you
give me a minute or
two represent hacken Phillips I I I was
here last term when we had a specific
bill um with an appropriation that um
was defined as folks who had uh lost um
some money due to
some Investments I'll try not to
characterize what type of Investments
but um you know I I do believe that
there were very few limited people who
benefited from that
appropriation and that was not deemed
unconstitutional and in this case we are
talking about a family um who will
benefit from this appropriation so again
it's another class of folks that will
benefit so I don't believe there is a
constitutional concern and furthermore I
believe that the Senate has clearly had
the moment and the time to think through
the same issue and they found it fit to
pass it along to our house uh
furthermore the policy committee also
approved it so here we are looking at
the appropriation and I think it's our
duty um on this committee to really
focus on that Financial commitment and
whether or not the state um is capable
of making that appropriation so I I
would move I hope my colleagues will
join me and move forward with approving
ought to pass for
604 thank you so I have the section and
I would just say that we are all
individually sworn to uphold the
Constitution and whether others read it
in a different way or whatever that's
you know that's you're referring to
article 10 right of Revolution yeah it
that that's just that's not actually the
title is not part of of the Constitution
that's that's put in by the Secretary of
State but what it's here's the first
sentence government being instituted for
the common benefit protection and
security of the whole community and not
for the private interest or aument of
any one man family or class of
men all right so government is not for
anyone the ENT of any one man family or
class of men which is
how I would describe this bill we could
deny payments to
employees I mean it's it's kind of wide
contracts yeah um even
$100 M Mr shair yeah represent hle thank
you Mr chair um I would like to note in
the docket that this has not gone via
any house policy committee that when it
came over from the Senate it was
referred to finance directly and not
through let's say Edna which it might
have been because it is a typical policy
that would have gone through Edna that
for some reason in the process it
skipped a policy committee so I do think
having policy discussions might be
appropo in the fact that on the docket
it did not get to a policy committee
this
time thank you further
discussion representative Maguire thank
you Mr chairman and and again the reason
we're passing this bill or or or want to
is not because it was officer hos
specifically it's because of the
situation he was in right it's it it is
for a general purpose right we we would
want to give this benefit to anyone in
that situation whether it's Joe Smith or
hos or anybody else right so that's the
whole point of of passing the amendment
thank
you representative grot thank you uh Mr
chair I just want to tell the committee
that because the bill was written as
such and did not include specific policy
that is why it went directly to finance
and did not need to come to anything to
anyone else thank
you further
discussion if there is no further
discussion the clerk will call the role
on the motion ought to pass without
Amendment on Senate Bill
604 thank you Mr chairman represent
Mooney yes representative Maguire
no representative uh
ner
yes representative Petri
volz wait a minute going to put in the
right place here representative em yes
representative Griffin yes
yes representative Bean
yes representative hole
no represent Sweeney
yes representative Campell
yes representa Popovich Muller yes
representa walner
yes representative leean yes
representative grot yes representative
Lane
yes representative Heath yes represent
Shu
yes representative eel yes represent
torki yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham
yes repr grassy yes repr priest
yes Mr uh representative uh W
yes Mr chairman the vote is
22-2 against the motion
passes Minority
Report I'm
so well it's oh and one absent
correct yeah it's it's ought to pass
it's 22 to2 22-2 with a Minority Report
of interim
study all right now I believe we have an
amendment for
553 and rep representative Sween is
recognized to describe it Mr chairman at
this time I move Amendment 1910 H to uh
Senate Bill
553 uh this bill I'll second it thank
you thank you representative uh this
bill we we certainly heard a lot during
testimony about it we've taken the
Senate version of the bill and we've
scaled it to a an encouragement Bill and
that's that's really the best way to
describe what this amendment does is it
encourages that funds deposited in PP uh
be invested in collateralized in New
Hampshire uh with the shall strive
language to make that encouragement but
it also makes it so that they shall
obtain the highest rate uh rating
possible uh for stable local government
Investments uh so it's really trying to
build the strongest system possible
while encouraging reinvestment into the
state of New Hampshire we certainly
heard about the economic benefits
investing in New Hampshire will and we
heard the concerns from the towns and
counties uh so this amendment really
does seem to fix
strive to fix uh by encouraging the
investment in the state of New Hampshire
while ensuring that return on investment
is still the the priority of it uh the
the new version of the amendment as I
referenced earlier has a sunset clause
in it so that it will be repealed come
December 31st 2030 so the uh that goes
into effect December 30th 2030 that
provision of the repeal um so that we
can have an opportunity to review in the
coming years whether or not this policy
change has a notable impact on PP or the
community towns and the investment and
the future legislature can go from there
um so the sunset provision is in this
amendment uh and the I think the
concerns that were brought and a good
deal was was struck on the underlying
bill so thank you in line 20 uh Roman
2A it is a little
confusing no less than 30% of the funds
held by the public posit public deposit
investment pool and insure in insured or
collateralized deposits that meet the
requirements it seems like we're pushing
that back into the bill that we didn't
want in there so so thank you Mr
chairman that sentence does start that
phrasing starts with the term shall
strive which is an encouragement with no
enforcement mechanism so it's simply the
legislative intent to d uh for for that
to occur with no enforcement or
requirement that that be the the case
it's simply purely
encouragement the original bill as
presented from the Senate was 100% in
invested in insured and collatz in New
Hampshire so it's it's simply
encouragement that 30% B representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair uh two
points the first one is a small one I I
think I heard you say December December
31 2030 for Sunset I I I thought June
30th 2030 was being floated what are you
did you say it the way you want it yeah
sorry I I had it as December 30th
2030 okay the I I had talked to a
lobbyist or somebody and it sounded like
because of the Contracting Rhythm Jun
June 30 was the was the right day of
2030 but I'm I'm not going to okay bite
over months after so they can still fix
the contract before followup followup
and and then when this was being
discussed with a a a friend from the
other body um it was suggested that line
21 would be up to 30% not no less than
30% what what what kind of discussions
did have been had about 30% whether
we're trying to create a a a a ceiling
to strive for or a floor to to not fail
to meet I I think thank you for the
question repres I think with the
language of shall strive the different
up two or no less has no practical
impact since it's we really just want
them to get to 30% but there's no with
no expectation or requirement to get
there uh I think the terms obviously if
if the other body feels strongly about
that they can form a committee
conference and I would volunteer to
serve onor all right thank you for the
answers representative
Griffin uh thank you Mr
chair the uh public Deposit Insurance
poll was great as something 30 years ago
and has been a great
success its goal has always been to
obtain the best return available with
safe
investments in that time it has never
lost money it has grown to nearly 700
million invested by counties and
municipalities SB 553 seeks to change
the pools investment policies in two
ways Investments must be deposit in New
Hampshire Banks and they must be ensured
are
collateralized the uh the Amendments
that are offered Sofer those
requirements somewhat but there's no
need for amendments this bill is a bad
Bill and we should not pass it all the
users of the pool that we heard from
oppose the law due to the likely
deterioration of their investment
returns in 2020 3 the law was amended to
place the trust under the state
treasurer the state the state treasur
and the pool's advisory committee are
currently reviewing and developing
policies and objectives for the pool the
legislature should let that process play
out without mandating a geographical
constraint on that process that may
limit the pool's returns please support
the Judgment of your County city and
your town treasurers by opposing this
bill I plan to oppose the
bill and uh if the Amendments pass they
soften the bills somewhat but even the
amended bill I plan to vote
against further discussion represent
grassy yes Mr chairman I I'm not opposed
to the amendment because I think the
amendment makes the bill better than
what it was as far as the municipal and
town and and and trustees of trust funds
that are out there currently and and I
think that it really you know just makes
it aspirational I'm a little wondering
why we have to Sunset something that's
aspirational but obviously that's what
the bill the amendment that we have
before us and I'm willing to to support
the amendment but I will oppose the bill
because I think that you know as
representative Griffin said we had just
about every Town Administrator and
County Administrator here T telling us
that they did not want to see this
change they want to see us to to to not
do this this time to let the state
treasurer it's only been put into her
hands this past year to let the state
treasurer work on their policy and and
then if there's a you know if if there's
a problem uh you know we can deal with
in the future what I would recommend is
that we take the amended bill and we
send it to inim study because that's
something I think that we need to take a
look at to address the issues that they
have because the this negotiated
settlement was not not done in
consultation with any of the towns or or
Trustees of the trust funds this was
something that was done by the treasurer
and the banking and the and the bankers
Association I think that you know this
has been let the treasurer do their job
let's inum study this to see what
happens over the next 12 months and then
we can you know a bill can possibly come
in in the fall if nothing happens over
the summer to to deal with this issue
but right now we need to have more
involvement by the municipalities in
this and that's who we represent is the
municipalities
and yeah that's why I will I will vote
to support the amendment but I will
oppose the bill I think the orders I
have of of questions is going to be
representative Stringham representative
papichi then representative Hull
representative Stringham is recognized
thank you Mr chair uh I was intending to
not uh support the uh the base bill but
I am going to support the amendment and
I will support the bill as amended I did
talk to my cities and towns and our
County uh our County for example has 5
million and PP out of 35 million total
investment uh the rest is all invested
in state so there's still a lot of money
uh I believe uh uh going that direction
um and um but there was a siment that
this is State money and it makes sense
that that uh everything else being equal
would be good for the money to stay in
state and um with an aspirational
amendment uh that's put forward this way
um uh I think I think think that's
enough that uh uh when the fund is going
out to look at places to put their money
I believe I heard that uh there was 20
Banks they do business with none of them
in New Hampshire uh it it'd be nice that
uh they consider New Hampshire as part
of that
portfolio uh and um I think this uh
amended Bill does that and uh I
complement both The Originators and the
amends for for doing this work thank you
representative papovich Muller thank you
Mr chair in the interest of brevity I
will state that I second most of the
statement of my colleague representative
Grassi a couple of differences between
me and him I don't really see this as an
aspirational policy I see it as a soft
mandate with gentler wording so I will
support the amendment but I still
consider it something that will lower
the investment on returns my other
minor nitpicking is that we don't
represent the cities or the towns we
represent the residents of the State
directly and they are the ones I'm
concerned about because they will end up
having to take to pay higher taxes
because they will get less return on
their
investment and um to make a long story
short the last thing I'll say is that
there is this is not a all things being
equal if all things be were equal the
money would already be invested in state
it's not invested in the state because
there is more of a return to be made
somewhere else by forcing part of it to
be invested in the state we are lowering
this returns and this is why I'm going
to support the amendment but oppose the
Bill thank you repres hle thank you Mr
chair um my question is is there an
interest by the committee as a whole for
an inim study on this I've heard it from
one person I'm aware of some others who
are supporting the amendment because it
makes the bill less bad but given that
we're trying to do significant policy in
an off year is interim study a better
motion and is it possible to see if that
there's a majority to take that up right
now you would have to defeat the the
motion before us to take up another
motion
okay represent hacken Phillips thank you
Mr chair I was wondering if I could ask
representative Sweeny if he could speak
a little bit about the origin um of the
six-month Sunset maybe you could it's
not six month um oh it's a sixe sun okay
that makes much more sense and I retract
my question
representative grassy from yeah I I
think this is something this is first of
all I'm wondering why this didn't go to
Commerce instead of here it should have
went to Commerce first to have the
banking division look at that and I
think that this is something that
certainly if we've sent it interm study
that I was wonder if Commerce could
actually pick up the bill and study the
bill there in Commerce and develop
something because I think that would be
the appropriate place to have an interim
study
done representative Mooney thank you Mr
chair I do have a question question now
with regards to line 31 effective
date and then it proceeds to say section
four of this act shall take effect on
December 30th 2030
not U cease to take place on December
30th 2030 well that's typical the way
they write
repeals it refers to section 4 which is
so there are two effective dates in the
bill on the second page the remainder of
this act sh take effect upon its passage
so only the repeal section takes effect
on December 30th
2030 so further further questions
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman and representative
Lane yeah I'm I'm in agreement with
representative grassy and Griffin on
this um this is policy that's been in
place since
1991 there's an advisory commit ittee
that helps the head of the program which
was for a long time the banking
commissioner last year we changed it to
the treasure but it helps them set
policy for these for this fund and that
committee includes two New Hampshire
bankers and so that committee is
perfectly um capable of implementing
this policy that's in this bill if they
think it's prudent the fact that they
haven't done so in 30 years tells me
that it's it's not a good
idea um and so I don't think you know we
we specifically asked in committee we
asked the treasurer is there a sense
that there's something wrong with this
fund that needs to be fixed and she said
no you know that that it it it's not a
case of something you know broken that
needs to be fixed so and all the people
that came to testify who actually have
money in the fund are happy with it and
don't want changes so so I again I'm I'm
in I'll vote for the amendment but not
the bill itself repres Lane um thank you
I get I want to go back to line 21 on
the comment uh that was made I think was
by representative
Edwards I I do think it's important to
make it up to uh 30% because that is the
ceiling if you say less than you can't
go below 30 that so that is requiring
them to invest in 30% and I don't think
that was the
intent um of the compromise but I I
don't know for sure but I I would say um
while I'm favoring in general this
amendment I I can't vote for it as
written unless somebody can explain to
me that I'm wrong which I often am so
thank you represent Sweeney will exempt
thank you and thank you for the question
so it it the full phrase does start with
the investment advisor selected by the
state treasurer and advisory committee
shall strive to maintain no less than
30% of the funds the the phrasing shall
strive is what makes it the
encouragement certainly no less or up to
or after the sh strive feel
interchangeable at that point there's no
requirement in the law that it be 30%
the striving is the encouragement is to
get to no less than 30% but is not
required mandated or there's no and
there's no penalty to anyone if it
doesn't get to there it's simply
encouraging them uh yes it's encouraging
no less than 30% it's a take down from
where it was at 100% in the original
bill um so it's just to get to that
encouragement level but with the with
the wording shall strive it makes this
bill encouragement not a mandate uh the
only thing that is that is required is
in the second uh subparagraph 2 be where
the investment advisor selected by the
state treasur and advisory committee
shall achieve and maintain the highest
attainable rating for stable value local
government investment pools that is the
requirement that's in the bill the
section above is the encouragement uh
legislative intent thank you does that
answer your question all right follow up
thank you Mr chair wait a minute there's
a follow up for her question then I'll
come to
you um uh thank you representative
Sweeney I guess I would um respectfully
disagree with you um because when
somebody's parsing the words I think the
goal at least that I understood was to
invest up to and I know and it would be
striving to be up to so um I I have some
concerns with that uh part of it and my
thought was if if it doesn't change the
meaning to you to say up to could we I I
know we've amended this thing to death
but if we do that amend it and then also
change correct the the
um the uh effective date uh at the last
line on page one we could vote on this
tomorrow representative Griffin thank
you Mr chair all other things being
equal it seems to me that the state
treasurer and the and the advisory
committee would try and keep Investments
within the state particularly if the
returns were the same so I think this is
the bill and the all these amendments is
redundant I think either we should study
the bill make it on interim study or
just defeat it we really don't need it
we know that the uh
Treasurer has uh only recently taken
over control the treasurer's office and
she test testified that they are
currently reviewing policies with the
advisory committee and um I think we
should let that process work its way out
the people already have the ability to
invest as they see fit in New Hampshire
and I can't imagine that they wouldn't
if they were getting the same returns
and the same
safety represent Edwards on R and rotate
uh thank you Mr chair um 48 hours ago I
would have wanted to have said exactly
what representative Griffin has said and
in the course of some phone calls and
and discussion with colleagues I respect
uh I I was willing to do this on a
limited trial basis for five years see
how it works out but I really had it in
my head that it was a sealing of 30% and
and I I and I understand the power of
the strive to comment I get that but it
still seems to me like it's sending an
opposite guidance message than the one I
intended to have us send and and so I I
think I I'm I'm I don't really want to
support this amendment as written and I
apologize if I fail to communicate to
that but uh interim study would also be
a really great alternative
thank you Mr chair
so I'll support the amendment I
understand the up to or no less than but
that's something that we can
change and I do think that this is a
good option for New Hampshire because it
keeps the money
here what to me if the interest rates
within New Hampshire are not competitive
enough then the treasury has the option
to go elsewhere but I think giving the
chance for New Hampshire to have this
These funds and use them to build upon
the state is a great idea and I would
support and I hope that people will look
at it that way and this is an option we
are presenting an option that is good
for the
state representative hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chair I just um want to
allay some of the committee's
concerns as some as a former Banker
myself I uh understand the important
importance of the community reinvestment
Act and the true trickle down benefits
to our community here in the state when
banks are putting more development funds
into their service areas now those
values of those properties that they
invest in create more tax revenues for
our communities and that trickles into
the state so we can provide more
services so there is a secondary perhaps
uncatchable um benefit you know it's
it's hard to quantify that um
immediately but we do know from the
folks um who have really run the numbers
and reported on this issue that there is
a huge un you know potential benefit to
to our state that can come as a
secondary benefit from whatever
perceived minor or um you know di
Minimus loss of investing from you know
moving those investments from out of
state to into state so you know I really
think that the sky will not fall if we
in fact undertake this opportunity um I
do think that the timing of the six-year
you know trial is a responsible amount
of time to see if this is something that
can take hold and benefit our state I
believe we would see that secondary
benefit within that time period um and
and I have overheard observed the the
treasur speaking with the prime sponsor
of this bill talking about the
importance of sending the policy
committee a piece of legislation that
gives them direction to try to strive
for this 30 percentile um or some
threshold amount for for the state for
these Investments so you know that's an
important signal to send to that
committee and to the treasurer so I
really believe that you know we should
not be sending this to interim study I
think this is something that we can act
on um immediately and um you know
whether or not it's up to our or at
least the 30% threshold I think is
really not critical I'm happy to defer
to the community on that or to the
committee on that um it's just this is a
really really strong opportunity for our
state to really sweep up some of the
benefit from the pp that is not
currently being realized in our state
because those Investments are going
frankly internationally so U for those
of us who have really dug into the Weeds
on the issue and
to the division who have really dug into
this issue um I think we would be
missing a huge opportunity for
investment in our state if we just put
this into inam study I think you know
every day is critical and this money
could really be put to use for our state
and I I hope the committee will um I
hope they will see that secondary
benefit and vote with it okay I've got
uh three people waiting to comment
representative papovich then
representative cabri kemell and then
representative GR
thank you Mr
chairman um to make a long story short
there were comments made that we need to
give New Hampshire investment opportuni
is a chance I can assure you that they
are having this chance right
now I mean there is nothing preventing
the PDP from investing in New Hampshire
if the returns in New Hampshire are
appropriate the point of the PDP PDP is
to give municipalities an option to make
a slightly higher interest trade by
assuming a slightly higher amount of
risk because the insurance are not
collateralized and or guaranteed or
insured the current Amendment which I
will support it because it's less bad
than the current
bill seems to be worthy to say at least
30% and why not 100% to be fair because
once you say no less than 30% there is
no upper limit look the opportunity that
we are missing here is the opportunity
to force the municipalities to take a
lesser amount of return on their
investment and therefore it's an
opportunity to burden our taxpayers a
little bit more but boy will we feel
good about it so I would appreciate if
uh people tell you that in investment
there are all those unquantifiable and
unmeasurable benefits to remember that
you can always always count dollars and
cents and that our job when we give
these opportunities to invest to our
municipalities and therefore our
citizens is to not chain them with so
many rules that they cannot make any
returns because we want to micromanage
where the money
goes in the interest of brevity I will
stop here if anybody wants to spend a
pleasant hour in the hallway I'll be
happy to
expand representative camell thank you
Mr chair I think we're overthinking it
this is simply an encouragement
Amendment there is no mandate here not
even a soft mandate and I got to think
with currently 0% of the fund being
invested in New Hampshire there's got to
be a little bit of room there to look at
New Hampshire and even if this does
nothing more than get in the future 5%
investment 10% investment in New
Hampshire it's a good thing and again
it's strictly an encouragement Amendment
and I will be supporting it
representative grassy no yeah the just
just two things I'd like to point out Mr
chairman first of all most of the larger
cities in this state you know some of
them use the pool some of them don't use
the pool because they have their own
Financial invest advisers and so this is
for the smaller mostly for the smaller
towns to be able to pull their money
together that's why it's called the pool
but I think that the thing that's that's
important to to think about here is that
this will really not impact anything
until next year because there's a
current contract that's out with the
investment advisors that we currently
have that will come up next year we have
time to put this into interim study to
study it and have a bill that will come
in that will direct them any changes for
next year in the in the meantime the
state treasurer and the advisory panel
that over that oversees this can can
work on regulations and take a look at
what these changes are for the next
contract what we're doing here is is
doing something that's going to impact
the next contract which I think is like
next March or June I'm not sure exactly
of the date but we have time to impact
that by submitting legislation in the
fall and you know so so doing this now
will not do anything next month or two
months from now or three months from now
it's going to be in the next contract
and what it what we can do is we can
study this and we can work with the
treasurer and we can meet with the
advisory panel and see or the Commerce
Committee can meet with them to make
good recommendations for good
legislations if we need it we may not
need it as most of the people said when
they were here if it ain't broke don't
fix it and it isn't broken
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I
believe in the people of New Hampshire I
believe in their
communities I believe in their
future and I believe in order to have a
bright and shiny future for New
Hampshire we need to in make the
necessary
Investments and I was going to give my
support to the original bill but the
amendment that representative Sweeny has
provided to us today I think makes it
even better because it's only an
encouragement for communities to
consider investing back into New
Hampshire and I think by investing back
you make our future you guarantee our
future a brighter uh a brighter one
thank you representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman I'm afraid
that a number of members are misreading
this amendment as compared to the
original Bill if you look at the
original bill on line page one line 8
one of the phrases invested or deposited
within the state of New Hampshire that's
the geographical thing is actually
missing from from the amendment so the
amendment no longer requires These funds
to be invested or deposited within the
state of New Hampshire the key line that
is the same in both is actually in the
amendment line 22 insured or
collateralized
deposits so that's the same as as in the
original Bill and that's the the part of
this uh amendment that pushes the money
into a bank because and and and
disallows other kinds of Investments say
commercial paper or money market funds
or
whatever which are not insured or
collateralized and that sort of the
source of of Greater returns is is
having I mean they're they're quite safe
but they're but they're not insured or
collateralized insured or collateralized
is what makes this A Bank in investment
that's my understanding but but
specifically it no longer says invested
or deposited within New
Hampshire representative Griffin many of
the comments uh we've heard here
particularly those in favor of the bill
operate under the assumption that of the
$700 million in the fund none of it is
invested in New Hampshire I'm afraid I
can't tell you exactly how much is but
I'm sure a portion of the money is
invested in New Hampshire and by moving
this inm study we can get an answer to
that
question further
okay are we ready for the
question the amendment before us is 1
1910 on house on Senate Bill
553 can we do this with a show of hands
without objection 1 1910 1
1910 those in favor of adopting
Amendment 1 1910 to uh house bill Senate
Bill 553 raise your
hands all right good vote and and the
amendment is adopted
25 I voted I did did not vote for
it okay
2023 23 then 23 to
two um now the next motion
representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman I move
ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill
553 and I think we've uh debated uh the
amendment and the underlying Bill uh so
I have no further things to add thank
you I'll Amendment you
second ought to pass as amended I
apologize we've been chatting a while
right okay motion of ought to pass as
amended with Amendment 1 1910 for Senate
Bill 553 further discussion seeing none
the clerk will call the rooll on the
motion of ought to pass as amended
Senate Bill
553 thank you Mr
chairman resent Mooney yes res uh nter
yes callau
me representative Maguire
no representative Petri votes don't
know did you vote I I vote Yes but it's
it's sketchy representative emry
yes representative Griffith
no representative uh Edwards
no there a bean
no res a hole
no resent a Sweeney
yes represent camell
yes represented Papa Muller
no represent
walner
yes representative leean yes
representative Grody yes representative
Lane
yes represent of Heath yes repr of Shu
no representative uh evil
yes representative tki
yes represent haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham
yes represent grassie
no represent priest yes
repr wer
no Mr chairman the boat
is 15 to 10 I think it's to
nine nine we're all here right I had
nine
opposed should should be 10 16 to to
nine you had 10
opposed yeah you you made the 10th one
all right 10 opposed it's
15 it was 15 you're going to do the
minority what's the motion on
the interim study Mr chair what is The
Minority Report inter stud interim
study
okay excuse me Mr
chairman all right excuse me Mr chairman
can you clarify the vote please because
I got 169 and I just is that what you
got
154 10 opposed is that check with you no
I got 16 to
n let's do it again well the the record
shows 10
NOS right that's what I thought but
let's
let's how many NOS were there 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
n nine all
right 16 to
n good this is it's not going to change
anything no I it just got it should be
corre I thought it was nine as well he's
got 10 on the paper by name all right
let let's do let me call him out the no
yes
Maguire no
Griffin is a no Edwards is a no Bean's a
no Cole is a
no papich m is a
no chew is a
no he can Phillips is a
no that was a yes
sir okay all right sorry about
that all right 16
to9 all
right right
all right
so we're going to uh which which one of
we're going to call people on
453 uh one which which was the the U see
what they think of it in the senate for
the Statewide vote on the interim we
think that the Senate has killed that so
find out before we return to Senate Bill
45 Mr chairman yes I I can tell you what
my plan is I I spoke to um assistant
Secretary of State Hennessy she's going
to speak to Senator gray about those
details right good but one thing we can
do and I'm we're going to draft an
amendment is to change the
$450,000 to a dollar and that way we can
pass it as a dollar and if at some later
time they they decide they want it they
can come back for a committee of
conference we can go back to
$450,000 so all right that's the that's
the right way to do it I I was mistaken
so you'll have that Amendment for
tomorrow we'll have that for tomorrow
all right 453 is
[Music]
tomorrow all right let's see what else
we have and he's doing a Minority Report
on
5 representative Griffin is writing a we
do have an amendment for 591 if you want
to discuss that now represent
Griffin uh 591
we we haven't done anything on that one
yet have we no that's next all right Mr
chair we have three amendments we have
the one from the division one for uh
representative Maguire one for
representative Mooney we'll hand them
all three out all on 591 yes I'll handle
all three
out yes
um we've always had um issues relative
to uh the Youth Development Center in
division 3 why is it that it went to
division one this time just I'm
curious why did it go to division
three it was it was more in Department
of Justice than it was Department of of
Education which
is
yeah and and division one Justice
treasury are in there that division so
that's that's why we switched it over
there all right
um have we got all the amendments
another one to
go all right we got one lengthy one here
we can well most of that's
eliminated all right we'll take some
time reading these
amendments yeah I'm
only Mr chairman I'm I'm personally only
planning to move Amendment 19 1911 if
that's the one people want to
concentrate on so you won't be bringing
1832 forward no
okay
and just to explain 1911 briefly while
you're reading it eliminates paragraphed
uh Roman 14 from the bill so
okay everyone has 1911 in hand will
recognize representative McGuire to
explain it thank you Mr chairman so
um this bill Senate Bill
591 um allocates $60 million for the YDC
settlement fund uh that's on top of $100
million that was previously allocated
and it also makes quite a few changes to
the um to the procedures of the
settlement fund and and limits and
deadlines and things like that so what
we heard in committee was that the
original thought two I guess it was two
years ago when when the100 million was
allocated was um that that was there's
some argument as to whether some people
may have thought that was all it was
going to be or that was a down payment
or whatever but what the what the
Attorney General told us was that we
expect to be liable or we expect to pay
claims um
totaling roughly um $750 million on this
on this um matter that because there are
something like 1,500 victims and claims
have been averaging roughly a half
million dollars a piece so that works
out $750 million so even if but this $60
million plus so far they've spent 85 so
they have 15 remaining so allocating
another 60 that's enough to carry us
through the end of the bium because uh
that would give us 75 the bill itself
has a limit on how much the state must
pay per per year and that's 75 million
so this carries this bill would carry us
through through the end of the
bium um the bill also creates a uh an
installment plan kind of scenario so
that so that um victims will be paid you
know so much per year until they're
fully paid um with a 5% interest rate on
unpaid
funds um what does my Amendment do so um
my amend
Amendment um eliminates paragraph
14 um which is found I think on page 14
of the bill um and that's the paragraph
that allows us to borrow money to pay
this
settlement right so one thing I did talk
about when we were had this in committee
was in in division was that it's
inappropriate I think to borrow money to
pay operating expenses and so uh you
know this you might consider this in a
gray area I just don't think I think
it's fine to borrow money to build a
prison to build roads to do Capital
costs but I don't see settling lawsuits
as as capital costs and so uh this would
eliminate the possibility that money is
borrowed to pay this
claim and I'm happy to answer questions
thank you questions from committee
members for representative
Maguire
motion representative Lehman thanks Mr
chairman have you run this amendment by
the Attorney
General um thank you for the question no
just the speaker and those those type of
people okay but but one thing one thing
I I did it I did hear from um the
attorney general and actually it's not
it's the Assistant Attorney General I've
been talking to about this is that the
whole bill is is a result of um is a
result of negotiation between the state
and the attorneys for the plaintiffs and
and so um and so a lot of the details
here um are are result of that
negotiation I we I considered other
changes in particular I think the the 5%
interest rate is a bit high and I would
change that to something lower but um
that's presumably a negotiation item the
exact way we come up with what this
amendment changes is that we're not
borrowing money I mean that's that's
strictly our business it you know the
way we come up with funds that's up to
us that's really not a subject of
negotiation further question
representative em yeah thank you Mr
chairman I would also comment that the
original uh position on this for
plaintiffs was that they could be paid
out over time going into this that was
part of their agreement is that they
agreed they could be paid out over time
so we're not introducing anything new
there thank
you representative Mooney is is your
Amendment could it be part of this one
or is it separate
um separate
okay question over here representative
grot thank you I have a question for
representative
Maguire in regards to the attorney's
fees uh line
22 how did you come up with the
33.33% yeah thank you for the question
so it reads as though my amendment is
doing that but it's just the way it's
drafted that's from the original bill um
and it and it is part of I I believe
it's actually existing law yes so so
that was part of their original the
original law that created the settlement
fund and so on the the reason it sort of
looks like it's part of the amendment is
because we're crossing off section 14
the very first paragraph and then we're
repeating all the following stuff as
though what used to be 15 is now 14 what
used to be 16 is now 15 and so on if you
see what I mean so um all that stuff at
the bottom is is from the bill and a lot
of it is from existing law apiz so the
part that you are referring to is the
very first PR lines four through eight
that's what's being removed by this
amendment right but okay thank
you represent Abel thank you thank you
Mr chair Mr chair having not seen this
amendment before considering that this
is an
unbelievably important uh bill that
we're discussing here
i' I mean speaking for myself I mean I
I'm just really uncomfortable doing
something like this at the last minute
in executive session in
finance without at least an opportunity
to caucus or to just put it on hold for
a day and understand what this
does I don't know how others feel any
others U support that raise your hand if
you do
yes
okay representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to just say something
along those lines and that is the
alternative to amending the bill is
ought to pass I think and and the
problem with ought to pass is this is a
$60 million hit to the general fund and
if we just say ought to pass it it's
going to go straight to the governor
this was not amended by the house and so
um and so they're they're potentially is
future negotiation over what what uh
burdens we can place at the on the
general fund at this time how much money
we have and so on so if we don't amend
it
that takes this particular Bill away out
of those negotiations whereas if we do
Amendment it can be they can ask for
committee of conference in that
Committee of conference the total
general fund can be considered and so
that's why I think an amendment makes
sense thank you okay representative able
yeah just one other I mean if the
discussion is where the money comes from
and doesn't come from like whether it
should be bonded or not whether it's the
rainy day fund that I understand but I'm
just not there's all this other about
the nego the uh attorney general and the
the fees and you know it just seems
pretty complicated to the uh uneducated
eye I would say
so I
don't I can see where we might need
another amendment but maybe not this one
but I say that without the benefit of
much time to look or absorb this at all
representative
tki I was just curious if um I know that
we haven't introduced it yet but if
representative Mooney described what her
Amendment does it may help us in our
deliberations of what to do with the
First Amendment all right let's
recognize representative Mooney so she
can describe her Amendment and the
reasons for it okay thank you Mr
chairman so I'm referring to my
Amendment it's number
1891 h it's very brief and I'll give you
some background and describe it I was
here last term when the fund was created
and I always had uh some discomfort with
the fact that there was a
2year window to file claims two full
years now the argument was made by those
who were advocating for that window that
it was needed in order to properly
publicize the creation of the fund and
then wait for claims to be filed it was
brought to light that perhaps uh
claimants would be incarcerated perhaps
living in other states perhaps
incarcerated in other states so I
accepted that argument um it worked
claims have been filed uh we're seeing
numbers coming in so to my surprise in
Senate Bill
591 the window is open another six
months with a deadline of June
2025 so my Amendment brings the deadline
to file a claim back to the law as it is
now and that is to close in December of
this year
2024 again keeping the window of filing
a claim at two solid years no more thank
you further discussion representative
rotate if um we could go back to
representative Maguire's Amendment
because I
think I
um I understand what this says so
paragraph 14 now
says lines 16 through 18 the cost of
administration of the fund and any costs
of the attorney general which are
outside of the ordinary operational
expenses shall not be paid for from the
fund that's what he's saying and then
the rest of the
Amendments excuse me leaves what used to
be paragraph 14 and 15 as paragraph 15
and 16 so really the part that is very
different is line 16 to 18 it's it's
just this part of
the of the amendment that is different
from the original bill would you say m
representative McGuire that that's
correct thank you for the question
so
um
the yeah so so if you look at the
original Bill page 14 or maybe you don't
have it in front of you um oh okay so
that's the issue
um
so the original bill in section
14 crossed off this stuff on line 4
through eight
okay it
added
um it added stuff that's not on this
page right it added a whole paragraph
about borrowing
money okay it it used to say in the it
says in the bill to provide additional
funds not otherwise appropriated the
state treasurer is hereby authorized to
and shall upon approval of joint fisc
and governor and counsel borrow on the
credit of the state for the purpose and
for said purpose May issue bonds and
notes and so on right so that was the
borrowing part okay the stuff that you
see on lines 4 through eight was
actually the cross outs that was in the
bill those were cross outs in the bill
the stuff on nine through 16 those cross
outs were in the bill all the stuff at
the bottom the cost of administration
all that stuff was in the bill see what
I mean so this amendment is eliminating
something from the bill that's not on
this
page okay it's it's on Page in the bill
it's on page 14 lines 20 through 26 and
it's all about borrowing it's not about
anything else someone from the lab just
generously loaned me their version and I
understand now thank you um as long as
I'm here I i' so that answers your
question yeah so let me let me speak to
um representative money's Amendment
which has my name on it because because
I was uh I was um contemplating it and
and it made sense to me but this is
something I did explicitly talked to the
Attorney General's office about and they
told me that this is the result of the
the the extension six months is a result
of negotiation and furthermore it was
something the Attorney General wanted
was this extension because because this
deadline is deadline for getting into
the settlement pool not a deadline for
filing a lawsuit right so if we short
keep the deadline for getting a
settlement that means and and some cases
that could have been settled instead go
to lawsuit that's quite expensive for
the state we have to hire attorneys and
and so on and go to court and time it's
time consuming and all that so um so
this is something and and the other
thing the attorney told me was that the
fact that this bill is making a whole
bunch of changes to the policy of the
settlement fund it takes them you know
once this passes in June um it'll take
them into August to create new um new
rules and and new policies for the
settlement fund that matched the bill so
that the the attorneys for the
plaintiffs cannot talk to their clients
until like August and so and to and to
explain to them here's one of your
options take the settlement and so and
so it it's there's so many clients that
it that the that's why these attorneys
want extra time to to for for the for
the uh for them to speak to those
clients rather than just the four months
at the end of this year right so that
that's the reason why they want the
extension so I'm I'm personally not
going to vote for representative money's
Amendment thank you representative
walner thank you representa Maguire just
said a lot of the things I wanted to say
but I mean the reason we set the
settlement fund up to begin with was so
that claimants could go through that
process and not through what potentially
could be a much more expensive process
of going to court so giving six
additional months makes a lot of sense
in being able to get um our CLA claims
in and um the um correct forms and
paperwork filed I am not going to V I am
not going to vote for representative
Mooney's um Amendment but I'm also not
going to vote for representative
Maguire's Amendment
um I've spent quite a bit of time over
the last several years working on this
um I know that this was very carefully
crafted
legislation um the attorneys for many of
the the claimants um were involved in
working on this bill along with the
Attorney General's office um and I did
not hear I did not hear from the
attorney general that he was looking for
any changes to the bill and that he felt
that there was any need for amendments
so I'm um going to support neither of
these um
amendments all right are we ready to
vote on
amendments representative Maguire is
recognized so I'll move a to pass with
Amendment 1911
H who was the second second
representative Hull was the second okay
show of hands for Amendment 1 1911 on
Senate Bill 591 all in
favor two
three 13 that's a
majority and I'll also like a vote
on uh representative Mooney's
vote what's that
all all
opposed I think it came out
right 13 to
12 all right okay Mr chair I'd like to
move amendment number 2024
H okay and
motion by Mooney representative seconded
by camell to adopt Amendment 1891 on
Senate Bill 591 all in favor raise your
hands all right opposed
defeated
okay who else is
County it looked like about 17
against 8 to
17 eight good is
any either way it was defeated all right
so now the the uh the motion the
amendment that has been adopted is 1
1911 to Senate Bill
591 recognize representative McGuire for
a motion of ought to pass as amended so
moved and the second
was representative Sweeney okay just as
it says in the script all right clerk
will call a rooll on the motion of ought
to pass as amended Senate Bill 591 as
amended by Amendment 1 1911
thank you Mr
chairman representative Mooney yes
representative naer yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papovich Muller yes Representative
walner
no representative Lehman
no Representative groy
no representative Lane no representative
Heath no representative Shu
no representative eel
no represent tersi
no representative of haaken Phillips n o
no beautiful
thank you representative Stringham
no representative grassy
no representative Priest No
representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in
favor of the motion okay the motion
passes now we have one left that we've
decided to wait till tomorrow because
you want to do some uh further
investigation on
453 Statewide voter registration system
there is still some loose ends on that
so tomorrow we have I think
representative Earth will be back um so
we may not need
representative um nter representative
shoot do you know how how long you won't
be here
tomorrow represent
Grody you only here for the
day representative Lane just for the day
all right so I'm going to pass
out some documents here just for the
members that are regular members of the
committee chair wer yes if I'm needed
I'll try to reschedule my day to come
thank you thank you have familiarity
with what we're discussing yes I do
Minority Report did you take one of
those yes I did okay uh is there going
to be a Minority Report on
representative
walner yes yes
you you'll do The Minority Report all
right what I'm passing out is it says
prepared for representative
wer so we passed I think it's about 20
some house buils out of this committee
my discussions with the other side of
the
wall I'm not meeting with a lot of
support so you'll see next to each of
those one two and
three so here's a number that I want you
to write above number one write six
above that 12 above two and the rest can
be three so this is your
priority oh all right where are they
going did you pass them
along oh yeah all right Pat all right
you're not going to vote on this
representative shoot pass it
along
so here's the
plan here we are as the finance
committee we work to get we worked on
all these bills in this
committee these are the ones that
passed
so if they're well supported by this
committee I want your
priorities so six you can give me six
number ones and 12 number twos then I'm
going to look at all the number ones and
I'm going to go see the Senate finance
committee and say
okay here's the ones we really have
priority if we don't get them you may
see them two or three more times as
amendments to whe the bills you
like so that's the way I want to proceed
but I want to feel that the committee
has some input to this that it's not
just my ideas but and and you may decide
it by the the amount of money or you may
decide it by the how you felt about the
bill representative Griffin thank you Mr
chair can we do less in column one and
two than the six and the
12 less
what can we column one you're suggesting
six can we do less than six in yes yes
if there's only two or three that you
really have priority to then that'll
help me representative walner yes I I'd
like to know if that when do you want
these back can we bring these back
tomorrow yes no I'm not not asking you
to do them today but I know we'll all be
back here tomorrow the regular members
and I want you to have time to look them
over and you know I don't I don't expect
you to make instant things right today
but some of these may need some some
study represent
hole so now that I have the form in
front of me right we get six we get to
select six for a number one and six for
a number two and the balance for number
three well 12 for number two thank you
and all the rest are threes and you
don't have to you don't have to score
everyone if you're not that interested
you might just give me your top ones or
it's up to you but I'll be I'll be
looking at the the ones that get number
ones I'll be scoring them all up
represent Maguire are these Anonymous or
would you like our name on if you want
to write your name that'd be fine if I
have any questions thank
you I didn't they didn't leave room for
your name but I would appreciate
it room at the bottom and any comments
where you say if I don't get this I'll
kill somebody or something extreme
but you know there obviously that
there's some that we on this committee
have put a lot of effort into some of
these bills and I don't like to see the
way the Senate's treating them represent
H um
thank you Mr chair but there's a huge
difference in terms of the spending for
several of these and should we be
encouraged to start looking at how to
get to a total below a certain dollar
value because two of these are the bulk
of this by themselves yeah some of these
are all the money all and so what I'm
looking at is there's if there's
something under a million dollars and
there's I've probably mentioned to you
before that I went to an arpa meeting
where I just was was me and the speaker
and couple of senators and and the uh
head of the budget and head of of gopher
and so on where they have
had arpa money that must be spent so
some of the projects that began
initially to be funded by arpa either
were cancelled or were delivered for
less money or
had got discouraged for whatever reason
some of that money is still here so when
I looked at went to the arpa meeting
here's three bills that you will see
tomorrow the Amendments that have been
prepared that the Senate has already put
ARA money one of those that you might
remember is the Hamstead property tax
they put that in the
um in the ARA money a fear that we
wouldn't approve it and there was a
couple others that escaped me for the
moment but I'll talk tell you tomorrow
so anyway if they're going to get arpa
money for their bills I want arpa money
for our bills so your money your choices
that come high on the priority list and
like like we know $50 million is going
to be a tough one but a million dollar
$2 million 100,000 200,000 that might be
there in the arpa money so I'm going to
go to the AR I'm going to go to the U
head of the budget there Jim gear and
say okay give me these bills as many as
you can take take this money and and
give me some more out of arpa we may
meet as late from what he said as next
November before we know how much of this
arpa money so some of these things may
not be funded right away but if the
Senate mistreats them and they don't get
passed uh there's another shot that
we've never had before so why don't you
all know about that and and wanted your
input before I just go well I like this
one the hell with everybody else that's
not me um want the input of this
committee we all work together on this
and so when I see what you like and I
like and we all like together we're
going to go forward to arpa and say hey
here's some we'd like to have funded
arpa funds it's not a done deal but it's
maybe better than what we're left with
at the time because these add up to a
couple hundred million or some of the
all the bills between the house and the
Senate and there isn't that much money
in the in the in the Surplus fund so I
was delighted to hear there's a little
bit more in the in the arpa it might be
into the millions it might be into the
tens tens of millions if that's the case
the money would either just lapse back
to the federal government or we could
use it for something that we
all you give me a vote telling me what
you like representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman what about the projects that we
are deliberating today and tomorrow they
don't appear on this table and some of
them have a cost significant
cost since the Senate has already
already shown the ones they wanted to
support in the arpa funds I figur they
their priority they've taken three of
the ones that we've done and and we
haven't done final knowledge on but I
will I will show you tomorrow by
amendments the three that they have
given alternate fundings and we won't
have to worry about but the Senate bills
if we like them we'll pass them and but
I'm I'm fearful the other side isn't
treating our house bills with the same
respect that some of you have gone into
their committee meetings they're given
10 minutes A
bill they're not even paying attention
to you they're looking at something else
then then they vote and some of the
bills that they've sent to us is at
first reading you see contradictions
within them didn't they read this I'm
afraid they didn't so we've amended
things that were obvious to us and tried
to fix them and uh you know
but I'm I just need another tool to
negotiate with them and so since we work
as a committee I want the committee inut
representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman one of my
favor seems to be a l lost from the list
House Bill
436 that was the $50 million for the uh
unfunded
liability
um ahuh but um I know that they have
already decided the uh either itl or
interim study on that one um and I would
point out um uh House Bill 1656 the
third highest one here special education
that one I know their committee voted 3
to one for for interim study ah so um if
we decide that that's a high priority
it's one we're going to have to attach
to some other Senate Bill next week
as a floor
Amendment right well yeah we'll have
we'll have we won't be meeting Thursday
so it'll be the it'll be the week after
which will give us time to get some of
these things done so that's why I'm I'm
going to work on this Thursday and then
get ready to go and do some actions so
that's the purpose of the 123 love to
see your names on it or if you want to
have give me any other hints on it um
that would be
appreciated I'm putting your name on
mine whatever works for you
Peter okay anything else to come before
us I appreciate all your fine work today
a lot of uh lot of busy work we had we
had a good um full committee today good
work by my by my clerk and
my assist my Deputy here or or not now
you're the assistant chairman acting for
today so and thank thank you for those
people that came and joined us
appreciate your input you obviously came
with some background on some of these
issues which is always a help especially
if you came from a committee where some
of this work was done yes tell us all
about what happened there so I don't
know whether whether who will be the
replacements for tomorrow but thank you
for coming in today appreciate all your
patience and all your time working with
us on these bills is there a move to
adjourn all in favor hi thank you very
much